but we got this poll from smussen oh
check this out so i'm sure uh for those
that are just tuning in
just for those that don't have the
context uh you're aware that riots have
been happening
we just went over how in lancaster they
had these riots
lancaster lancaster lancaster lancaster
we were saying that yeah we can't
pronounce words on this show what do we
look like
okay anyway lancaster lancaster okay
fine someone's tricking us
i think so i think they're pulling the
wool over eyes but i've seen it a few
times
oh i don't know google it pronunciation
someone trying to pull a fast one on us
anyway there were riots in this
central pa town about 60 miles west of
of philadelphia and uh they did 3am
raids
gave these people a million dollars bond
and boof the riots are gone
yes but so interestingly one of the
rebuttals i guess from the journalist
class
which are totally out of touch with
america has been the riots have been
small i can walk around my tent and
everything's fine
there's a video i love it's this dude in
like a wealthy area of new york
and he's filming himself fake crying
going oh it's so miserable in new york
look people are eating sandwiches at
restaurants and
people having ice cream and then he pans
a little more and ice cream shop is
called big gay ice cream
and he goes gay ice cream and then he's
like walking fake crying
and then he stops and he goes stop
watching fox news
you know why i think it's hilarious
imagine
going to like uh a
garbage dump and then going to the front
office
where it's actually a building and
there's like a playstation and the guy's
sitting there and he's playing games
and you're like i'm gonna garbage dump
this guy's got like he's got like a coke
machine he's got playstation it's so
nice and then out back it's just flaming
trash and garbage everywhere
you get these people who go to the
wealthiest areas and they're like
everything's fine
i'm atop my ivory tower and i've noticed
no problems with riding in the streets
yeah that's the
the chinese uyghur uh people have been
hitting me up on twitter saying it's not
real it's western media propaganda we go
i've went to
uh was this xinjiang i think is the the
and it's i
i toured where i went it was fine so
that means that it's not happening
potemkin villages
right yeah so here's the here's the poll
here's the poll
they like to claim that everything's
fine that you know look the protests are
in a small
area well check it out three out of four
voters
who've had violent anti-police protests
in their community rate those protests
important to their vote in the
presidential election among these voters
a
sizable majority like the job the
president is doing
the latest recipes and reports national
telephone and online
online survey finds that 42 percent of
likely u.s voters
have had anti-police protests in their
community this summer
nearly half of these voters say the
protests in their community have turned
violent
among all voters 65 say the violent
protests are important to their vote in
the presidential election this fall
with 41 percent who say it's very
important
among those who have had violent
protests in their community even more 76
rate them important to their vote
including 54 percent who say they are
very important
63 percent of these votes strongly
approve of the job trump is doing
versus 35 percent who strongly
disapprove now i'm going to stop right
there
where are these these uh riots taking
place are they taking place in the
countryside i don't think so are they
showing up to like amish town and like
no no they're showing up to like small
conservative church areas
no they're in urban areas they're in
urban and suburban areas and donald
trump needs to win the suburbs
interesting yes very interesting isn't
it
so these people who are answering this
and saying they've experienced these
violent protests
i'm willing to bet a large portion of
them it makes sense right
why it says 42 percent have had
anti-police protests in their community
yes
because the other 58 live in areas
outside of rural areas right people did
they pull for this
by the way two thousand like this is
ridiculous what do you mean how many
people got pulled i didn't get pulled
one thousand
a thousand people it's like that's
normal though so okay these numbers are
just like
you could almost call them irrelevant i
disagree um first of all i will say
in the sense that the polls have been
wild and outrageous across the board
yeah rasmussen actually was the most uh
one of if not the most accurate in 2016
as per
the uh the national popular results they
nailed it they
they got it right when you measure a
thousand people's beliefs that doesn't
mean that you just times ten it their
people are so
different everywhere you go it's true
it's true but they're not just
calling a thousand people in new york
and then being like well there we go
they're selecting a bunch of different
areas and then grabbing a few
people from each and then they do it's
it's it's just it's how polls work
inductive reasoning so i mean you can
argue the polls are bunk i will and
yeah yeah i think it's fair actually
because we've seen a lot of bunk polls
in fact
i was commenting on this earlier today
the real clear politics average for
trump
it's like plus three minus seventeen
minus six minus fourteen and i'm like
what's with that
insane swing because they'll pull like
two thousand people and then
six thousand people and one thousand
it's like there's three hundred fifty
million of us
if you're going to all one zero
different different methodologies
trillions of percent of a population
you're going to get vastly inaccurate
data
i disagree i think i think the polling
they do like they break it down and
explain to you exactly how they did it
it's a it was a survey of a thousand
likely u.s voters conducted september
9th to the 10th 2020.
the margin of sampling error is plus 3
minus 3 with a 95 level
95 level of confidence field work blah
blah they
they go through all of this stuff like
they break down their methodology for
how they
zoom in on one area interview a couple
people and then zoom out and then look
at other areas
so you can argue that it's definitely
like a game of sudoku where they're like
looking at all these people and trying
to fill in the gaps but there's a margin
of error
what a lot of people don't understand is
that the polls in 2016 were not
actually all wrong it was the pundit
class that were like if hillary
clinton's up two points trump will never
win
and then he did and he lost the popular
vote and rasmussen got it right
rasmussen said she was gonna win point
uh plus two
hillary clinton plus two so look you can
argue that the polls are wrong
or very small but uh but uh sure
but i think this makes sense um and
we'll extrapolate from there so first
42 percent of likely voters have had
anti-police protests in their community
i think that makes sense yeah that
sounds accurate
because because you got you got to
realize a lot of people are in densely
popu
packed uh you know urban centers so
one you know you get 10 protesters
marching through the street and 10 000
people are going to be like whoa we got
protests on the street
and then you've got 58 percent which are
suburb suburban
and rural who probably would never see
these
however a lot of the rural people are
watching the news and going like man
that's crazy you know
sending the cops arrest these people but
the fact that
you know so 48 said they turned violent
so that's like just shy half of those
who saw a protest
saw a violent protest that's intense
again assuming the polls are accurate
among all voters 65 percent say it's
important to their vote in the election
i i have to imagine these people are
probably suburban voters
i think if you take like a new york
liberal progressive they're going to
watch the riots and go woohoo
yay and they're going to lie about it
and they're gonna vote biden because
they hate trump and it's tribalist
would you take suburban voters who don't
know don't care
like actually a good example is this uh
the new york times went to kenosha
and they interviewed some guy who was
like i don't know anything about
politics and i don't care but man these
riots wow that's so messed up
now this person's going to be going to
the voting booth being like i don't know
man we need trump to come in and just
arrest these people right you don't
change your
your chief of uh you know your chief of
command during a conflict that's kind of
you know part and parcel for united
states government just government in
general you don't rarely
change your commander-in-chief when
you're in a war and if people see this
as a domestic war they're not going to
want to change their commander
i mean it's it's that that's true but
imagine this
let's say a trump uh trump biden debate
perhaps on joe rogan hashtag joe most
joe yes and
you know joe's like yo like we're
watching videos of these riots man this
is crazy
and then joe biden's gonna be like i
condemn the riots i called out the
violence
and then trump's gonna be like excuse me
you never said
black lives matter or anti-fun excuse me
your campaign no no joe your campaign
bailed these people out that's true dude
trump's on the pulse he's been following
this stuff
like a and a search dog dude trump is
the internet's candidate yeah
he's he's uh he's online his staff are
online they're plugged into what people
are talking about
the problem is the online left is is
is totally insane i know they're crazy
so weird like i love rachel maddow i
used to really like her and appreciate
what she does but
she just kind of went nuts with the
russiagate stuff in 2016. i was so
so disappointed and like where are you
taking these millions of people rachel
why why look at this she's like odd
scale
and they banned alex jones and they they
banned him
i mean the crazy thing about all that is
when alex jones goes on and says like
you know people the cell towers or are
mutating people into cows or whatever is
that
i watched the joey and podcast episode
with me talked about like animal hybrids
oh it's like dude i was in sweden and i
heard i'm at a thai restaurant
with my friend emily we were doing this
this project and all of a sudden we
heard alex jones and we're like
what what and we turn around and there's
three young dudes laughing as alex jones
is like ripping his shirt off
people knew a lot of what he was doing
with silly entertainment it was like wwe
he's talking about crazy stuff that
people found funny but rachel maddow is
she's a serious news woman right so when
she comes out and says
russia is coming to get you everyone's
like
yeah she's got a lot of people believe
her like right on her every word
and i have friends from l.a i was in la
you know the heart of the liberal
madness incubus at the time 2012 through
2016. it was where it was
really really becoming insidious and
they loved that girl out there
so whether or not this will actually
um whether whether people are really
experiencing this stuff the viral videos
i think
are making their rounds so some people
may not have actually seen a violent
protest or riot
i'm sure they've seen the videos of it
though you know i got a question that
you guys can help me with
i'm wondering if i'm suffering from
ivory tower syndrome because when i look
at this stuff i'm like
good arrest those people throw them in
jail don't let them out
good i want this to stop arrest them all
and it's like is that really the answer
or am i just
i'm not i'm not suffering right now
so i have no desire to go out and and
throw my body into a
into risk um and am i what suffering are
these people undertaking uh yeah well
they're getting in front of rubber
bullets you know they're taking a risk
so wait like if you go out to protest
and you want to wave a little sign that
says something like you know i don't
know
lower the cost of eggs bread and milk
you know what i realized
at occupy wall street going out there is
not the way to protest you use the
internet
if you want to protest make internet
videos you will change hundreds of
millions oh yeah
yeah yeah like we're doing right now joe
must show
joe biden donald trump joe rogan podcast
uh this is gonna get so many
whatever i hope it happens uh anyway
look
if you go out and you wave a little sign
saying the cost of milk is too is is too
damn high
and slam the table and then you're
sitting there chanting and then all of a
sudden some dude lobs a molotov
and you're like that's crazy i'm gonna
stay here with this man
okay well then you're gonna get with
rubber bullet man yeah like the cops
aren't gonna be like
which one wasn't there like the crowd's
throwing explosives and incendiary
devices i guess my question is is there
value to what they're doing
i've never i've never read this book by
the way um
is there value and i'm just missing it
because i'm in like the ivory tower
right now
well well depends on your definition of
value uh value in the sense of like
regardless of the intent is there a
positive is there something that will
help
it'll get trump elected if that's what
you want maybe but to fix like the
economic if there's a caste
disorder is this is this the way to do
it or are they missing the mark
completely
i think they're missing the mark
completely i think
peaceful protest works the scientific
data shows that
and if they took all of their energy and
just laid down in the street
then that's that works it does it's a
nuisance a lot of people get annoyed by
they get really angry
but it does work and then what happens
is the cops come in they pick people up
the people put their hands behind their
back comply meet with every officer and
the officer says yeah i get it i get it
don't worry you know you'll be out an
hour or two
they get a slap on the wrist charge the
court says congratulations you got your
mark of honor with the arrests
have a nice day and then the news
reports you know
broadway and you know whatever street
was shut down because people blocked the
intersection
and you get press attention for it i
think civil disobedience is the line
you are breaking the law but we all kind
of go okay
we get it and it's to get the attention
of the lawmakers so that they
change the exactly so then the lawmaker
is seeing there's a lot there's popular
action here they see peaceful protest
and they think this is good for me
so then they go on tv and said all of
those people they came out here and they
expressed themselves and they did it
right they did it peacefully we got to
stand up for that
so i am announcing a change we will
lower the cost of milk bread and eggs
when everyone cheers
and it does work and uh riots don't
riots scare people and make them say
send in the troops
so if you want to talk about value if
your value is donald trump getting
elected you should be thanking antifa
every day saying thank you for going out
and destroying things because just
proves trump was right the whole time i
guess it's why is he getting elected
that's
kind of almost as important maybe not
more important but what do you mean like
is he getting elected because people are
afraid
and they want a military like um what do
you call it like a
military government like martial laws or
they want to elect him because they love
his policies and they want to support
him to make
global peace at this point it's a little
bit of both because
a little while ago the economy was
really good and everyone loved him for
that
and now the entire country is up in arms
because
you know racial unrest and all this
stuff that's been going on that's been
so widely heavily emphasized by the
media and our politicians
so now we have both peace when trump is
in power
and chaos when it looks like the left is
going to get power so who do you think
is going to end up with the power
if the voters are watching this and
they're like what what kind of
i'll start i'm going to start with you
lady what kind of person are you if
someone said to me if someone said to
you if you vote for me
the violence will stop but if you vote
for for trump
the violence will continue make the
right choice who'd you vote for
make the right choice would you would
you vote for the person
you're going to tell me what choice to
make
hmm i don't know i didn't i didn't know
the right choice i should make the right
choice
i will make the right choice thank you
so you would so so same question
if someone said if you vote for me the
violence stops
but if you vote for him the violence
will get worse well a couple things
define
violence and how will you stop it are
you gonna
level it everything with a big explosion
that makes it nice calm and peaceful
and end the violence that way because i
don't want that or are you going to
eliminate it
no no no no joe biden didn't say he was
going to make the violence at all
they this war game they put out from the
democrat war game and the never trumper
war game said
unless joe biden landslides there will
be widespread violence yeah it's like a
fear tactic
it's nonsense also you can't you can't
decide that ahead of time
here's the best part you ready for this
yeah both trump and biden have said that
really yes donald trump has put out the
the you know in joe biden's america
don't let the democrats take over
oh yeah and and joe biden and the
democrats have said it's currently
trump's america and there will be
violence unless joe biden wins
so what about weinstein weinstein's uh
unity
unity platform it's just a third party
it's like
it's too soon to the election i think
for it to get real traction
but we need somebody that doesn't act
like that like
tulsi gallery well here here's here's
it's that's not it that's not it
i hear what you're saying but i actually
think trump is right
how so when trump comes out and says
that actually i think they both might be
right
well no you know trump says that if joe
biden gets elected
this is you know you'll get more of this
because he's weak on all these policies
and i think it's a fair point antifa is
taking advantage of him so
perhaps trump is wrong in the sense that
you'll see widespread violence what
you'll see is
successful militant far leftists because
joe biden negotiates with them and gives
them what they want
you get biden in he's going to turn
around and say do your thing and they're
going to be like here are the things we
want he's going to say
i'll give you half of it so he's
negotiating right now and he's off he
he did like the bernie sanders pact or
whatever
where it's not far left enough for the
far left but it's too far left for
moderates
so if joe biden wins the rioters
probably will still be doing their thing
but he's going to give them what they
want so
yeah you'll have violent lunatics going
around
but they'll just get whatever they want
if biden loses the violent lunatics will
start screeching because they're not
going to get what they want so they
start smashing things but i think either
way
we're in for some either way you're
still going to have violent lunatics out
there
in that mindset that's why i think trump
is right so it's not it's i don't think
it's the figurehead that's the problem
it's
no not only the class system you look at
what's going on with
the you know trump's plans already
deputizing oregon state police
i am the kind of person who says listen
you have a choice joe biden says
i'm going to give them if they want to
placate them trump says i will i will
send in
the police and i will have them arrested
arrest them no i'm airing on the arrest
side
no no you're not gonna you're not gonna
threaten me into voting for the other
side
so when trump comes out and he says in
his ads like in biden's america this
will happen
and the left is like well it's currently
trump's america and it's already
happening
and i'm like yes emboldened by the far
left and by democrat politicians at
local levels who won't enforce their
laws the d.a specifically
donald trump has taken action to
actually stop a lot of this some of it's
worked but i don't i don't care
you even if even if donald trump isn't
doing enough you think joe biden would
do more
no i don't think so it would be kamala
harris pulling the strings and i don't
like her military tactics
if i have the choice between the guy
threatening me
or i'm sorry i've if i have a choice
between joe biden saying
i'm gonna give in to a lot of the far
left demands so that it all stops and
the other guy is saying
i will make them shut up by sending in
cops and arresting them i'll say oh
arrest them you you're not gonna you're
not
you're not gonna i'm not gonna negotiate
with these people yeah that's a slippery
slope to negotiate with terrorists
exactly
and and what do you think these people
are doing to get what they want yeah so
that's that's the issue
in joe biden's america i do think i
think trump
look they're both to an extent being
like ooh violence if you look for the
other guy
and it's it's i guess you can't distill
this properly in a short ad
in joe biden's america you will have the
morality police
you'll have the people knocking on your
door saying that rap music is cultural
appropriation
i'm being a little hyperbolic i'm
exaggerating quite a bit but we're
getting to that point where the cdc
already has what is it 1 200 people
you know wanting a race racism to be
declared a national health crisis or
whatever
just like yeah we've seen like 40 cities
declare racism a health crisis
state of colorado colorado the whole
state did it yeah yeah i don't want to
live in a place like that that doesn't
make sense what does that mean
what do you do to stop that i have no
idea racist like we've already made
institutional racism illegal in 1964.
it's like we did it we stamped it we're
done
now there's a lot of other issues that
we can you can we can start fixing
remnants of historical racism and things
like that i'm all for that i'm a bit of
a lefty in that regard
what they're doing is not they're
creating more segregation i mean i'll
tell you right now
under so we we see a lot of segregation
happening
uh you saw the um university of
michigan-dearborn thing yeah dude
where they were like non-poc only
virtual event or something freakish and
then they like rescinded on that
well they apologized for their
terminology what they're still doing
i don't know i think they're still doing
it they just said we're sorry about the
terminology
it's a non-poc place but pocs can come
like that's just weird
well someone a person of color like come
on don't i don't
put someone in a category like that you
got california repealing their civil
rights law you got things like that
you got the town of freedom in georgia
where a bunch of black people are like
it's it's not necessarily a black only
but
white people can apply that's what you
will get more of under joe biden
what people don't realize is that trump
only just it's it's
we're coming on the end of his first
term and he just banned a critical race
theory
he's spoken about spoken out against
these things and his base is demanding
he does more and he likely will
and he's not a fascist that's ridiculous
i like it and and i've
i've seen uh you know he made a comment
on fox and friends about how he wanted
to assassinate assad
and that is horrifying yeah i don't like
that who said that
trump did oh my god in 2018 and mata
stopped him and i'm like uh
but i think trump made a lot of mistakes
you know john bolton foreign policy
stuff however we have three historic
peace agreements
that's pretty cool the thing is biden is
so
bad he's such a bad choice he was a
laughable mistake in 2008 just
a goof of a ridiculous mis why was he
even up on that stage
and obama for some idiotic reason put
him as his vp i still have no idea why
he did that
he was the least horrible or the least
likely to say yes to everything obama
wanted he's just a yes man
that guy is a nut he's a he's a lame
sub intellect uh liar and cheat
he he's a plagiarist and now he's
getting going into cognitive decline and
this is what he
trumps up against so yeah he's the worst
absolute
so what's really interesting to me is
when you talk about somebody's america
why don't you talk about the person
who's been in a position of power
for 47 years that's a good instead of
the person who's been in power for three
and a half years
this has been joe biden's america it was
for eight years
and he did it for 47 years joe biden's
america yeah he's been in office and
then when
and i know they both said this is going
to be the world that we live in after
this person's elected but with joe
it's like a promise that more will come
whereas with trump he's like look with
look what's what
look at what's happening right now we're
taking care of it
so i think it's different directionality
from each of them
like joe's like promising more of the
same more or less
i think this card on trump i think this
cartoon right here
sums up all that you need to see yeah
this is from george alex opolis he's
g prime85 on instagram and twitter and
this is just
excellent excellent artwork it is the
first panel
joe rogan all right gentlemen we
hydrated caffeinated ready to begin our
four-hour debate
the next panel is trump looking up
smiling with rosy eyelashes and there's
bright colors bursting behind them
then a a worried looking sweating joe
rogan who looks over and joe biden is
sleeping
and it's like a decrepit this is amazing
art
george this is really great stuff i love
the colors just like look at binding
dude that's that's that sums it up okay
so this does reference what we've been
screeching about the whole time joe
rogan getting this debate between the
two of them
but the but there's more here than just
the debate it's this
this this image of trump and biden is a
caricature it's an exaggeration
but it's an exaggeration it's it's
emphasizing the the
these people way way more trump you know
egotistical chin up you know smug
looking smug looking face
you know how he does that he's like and
joe biden's sleeping
and snoring and looking awful it's an
exaggeration i suppose
you know if it was more negative trump
you could have made him look bloated
with tiny hands or something
but i think it's an exaggeration of
trump as this like
you know arrogant you know smug more
famous
more money and more and the first one
you can see him smiling and looking over
like yeah yeah
and joe biden it's amazing
i think you know the left would look at
it the other way
they'd see joe biden like i don't know
i don't know do i really have to do this
and donald trump whining and
pounding on the table but that's a
caricature based on media lies about
trump
the crazy thing about trump is that the
media makes his portrayal of him like a
whiny baby
and i'm like trump can be that sometimes
but i really don't think trump cares
about this stuff the way they act like
he does
they're like did you see how mad trump
got because his ratings were bad i'm
like trump probably didn't even think
anything of that because he's watching
fox news
so it's like cnn comes out and they're
like donald
the rnc's ratings were lower than the
democrats
trump is mad am i right woo-hoo five
in reality trump's watching fox news and
fox is going
when you combine tv viewership with
online the rnc
trounced the democrats and trump's like
all right sounds good
so they act like he's mad he's probably
not mad so anyway let's do this let's
let's thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you